right now we're hearing the sun just
start to activate the uv sensors
on the
outdoor sensor unit
it started about 10 minutes ago
that puttering sound is the sound of
that sensor just starting to get enough
light to
sonically activate it
and the puttering will eventually turn
into a note
and that note will semitone by semitone
increase in pitch until it becomes
inaudible and then it'll be inaudible
all day long
until the uv drops to a point when you
can hear it
again usually at sunset but if it's a
cloudy or rainy day it'll activate all
day long
it's in we've just
just completed helicopter mode it sounds
like first it sounds like drums
and then it sounds like a helicopter now
it sounds like
a monster
soon it will be music
this is the mixers
and this is just a global delay on the
whole thing to give it to give the sound
some depth
nothing really is happening
it's not windy or raining or anything
very
exciting weather-wise but this music is
something that
is to be
almost breathed like air or bathed in
like water
but now you can hear the sun tone is now
in key with this
cord
it's on e
and it'll fall out of phase
i'll turn the delay off so
this is the cool [ __ ]
so
you